Essa notícia, Anvis acabou de aprovar um
novo medicamento contra Alzheimer que já
tinha nos Estados Unidos. Mas calma,
porque a história não é bem assim. O
Lecanemabido
como lequenbiado
para pacientes na fase inicial da doença
com comprometimento cognitivo leve. Pois
é, ele não serve para quem já tá em
estágio avançado. E tem mais, para usar
esse remédio, o paciente precisa
comprovar que tem placas de proteína
milóide no cérebro através de exames
específicos e não pode ter uma mutação
genética chamada apoe4, porque essa
variante aumenta muito o risco de
efeitos colaterais graves. Veja bem,
esse medicamento é um anticorpo
monoclonal que tenta reduzir essas
placas no cérebro e o efeito é bem
modesto. Ele pode desacelerar um pouco a
progressão da doença, mas não reverte
nem cura. E aqui entra a minha visão
como médico. A gente não pode depositar
toda a esperança numa pílula. O
Alzheimer é uma doença metabólica que
começa décadas antes dos sintomas.
Resistência insulina, inflamação
crônica, deficiências nutricionais,
toxinas, tudo isso contribui. Então,
sim, é um avanço, mas a verdadeira
revolução está na prevenção e no estilo
de vida, muito antes de precisar de
qualquer remédio. Aliás, antes de
terminar esse vídeo, eu queria falar
para vocês que o estudo Avanteia do
Recode tá na sua fase final. e descobriu
que mudança no estilo de vida e o
tratamento multifatorial são sete vezes
melhor do que esse tal de Lakenb.